this city bus looks like an ordinary
diesel-powered one but it's all electric
in June Manheim put three e buses into
service they can quickly be recharged at
the bus stops
the passengers don't even notice and the
driver can relax
even with over 6 million euros invested
in it this model has quite a long way to
go to become economically viable but the
project head is hoping that EBUS a--'s
will eventually become standard this is
not relative toya it's still relatively
expensive as a research and development
project the costs aren't commercially
feasible yet so we can't be compared
with other vehicles that's but a few
things are in the pipeline concerning
the battery among other things from
which we expect considerable reductions
in costs a button via dog leash across
the regiona the he buses were developed
by the Karlsruhe Institute of Technology
this laboratory produces lithium-ion
batteries electric vehicles or EVs need
cheaper batteries with longer ranges but
the German manufacturers still lag
behind their Asian competitors your
Kaiser worked for a German battery maker
for several years but this year it
closed its doors yet some yachts light
housing functions as things stand now in
2015 it looks as if the Europeans have
fallen behind in the development of
battery cell technology as watered sushi
in Germany they realized too late how
important lithium-ion cell technology
really is try to catch up with lots and
lots of state-funded projects but it
hasn't been enough a line is centralised
here researchers and programmers are
working on optimizing the software for
electric cars they collect data on the
vehicles battery charge status and
charging process the first time they've
been able to do so in such detail
the project is expected to give electric
vehicles a huge boost
the dardan Bearden some car owners need
the data to get a clearer picture of the
battery status at miss division they've
got a destination to meet so the vehicle
has to cover a certain distance in which
damaged image and photography she's
giving such take it so quickly image to
flash the driver has to know the car
will be fully charged the next day I
ended up other parties have an interest
in these data as well for example rental
car companies and motor pool operators
mia chef they have a business interest
in knowing that cars are available at
certain times the students in Karlsruhe
could well be the Eevee developers of
tomorrow they built this electric race
car themselves and entered it in
international student championships and
the formula e that's how the female
inflame excitement
this has more to do with perfecting the
technology than was pushing the limits
of speed steam emit deformed us too in
the formula students engineering and
competition and especially the Formula
Student Electric we can test what's
possible in electric mobility in the
coming years on my Romeo we have so many
sponsors investing in our ideas who
believe in us and in electric cars
he knows maybe we're doing the
groundwork so that in one two or three
decades will have more electric cars on
a German roads totals of dodging
thousands eat the car heads out onto the
track only a handful of drivers are
allowed to handle it the car was made of
carbon fiber and the motor was
custom-built it reaches speeds of 120
kilometers an hour
the students efforts are showing results
last year they won a major formula
earrings with this electric racer and
that's just the beginning